okay das ist unsere frage lotterien die
grünen sind höfliche fragen die
großen ein bisschen fies oh gza ich weiß ich
das ist diesmal eine höfliche wann und
von wem hast du dein talent und ich
weiß es nicht wirklich weil niemand sonst in
meiner  Familie wirklich Heilige oder macht irgendetwas
besonders Musikalisches, also weiß ich nicht wirklich
, woher es kommt, aber als
Schotten sind wir alle normalerweise
distanzierter. Ich würde mich nie wirklich als
talentiert bezeichnen. Ich würde sagen, dass ich es beflügele
und ich kann  die Noten zu halten, aber und ich
weiß nicht, woher es kam, aber
die Schotten sind sehr viele von
ihnen sind Musiker, ich denke, das ist ein
schlechtes Wort, es wäre eine schlechte
Verallgemeinerung, mich als Pflegerin der Gossage-
Leute zu sehen, Musiker, aber ich  Ich bin mir sicher, dass es
viele Leute gibt, die Musiker in
Schottland von ihm sind. Ich weiß nichts
, denkst du, es ist unnötig, einen Beruf zu lernen,
es ist eine seltsame Frage, ja,
aber in deiner Biografie ist Rafi, wir lesen, dass
du alles lehrst  selbst
ja Gitarre ein  d Ich habe meinen Beruf gelernt
ja aber nicht mit in einer schule das ist nicht
bis wir nicht das ist nicht das was ich hab ich
dich gefragt ist das nein ich denke nicht ist
wenig ich lerne den beruf und vielleicht
nicht in der schule aber ich bin trotzdem gegangen  zur Schule
und ich habe immer noch hart gearbeitet und ich habe immer noch
gute Prüfungsergebnisse und ich denke, wenn Sie
im Leben eine bekommen wollen und es
gut ist, einen Beruf zu lernen, und ich denke, die
meisten Menschen tun dies, werden die meisten Menschen dem
zustimmen, aber Ihr Beruf  du ich
nicht wahr ja es ist so so talentiert gut
ich habe es mir selbst beigebracht es lernt immer noch so
ja ja das macht nicht wirklich sinn
ok vielleicht am ende grün ok
frage
was ist das geheimnis deines erfolgs und ich
weiß es nicht  ist kein Geheimnis, ich
schreibe einfach Songs und gehe auf die Bühne und singe
sie und ich weiß nicht wirklich, warum die Leute
zu mögen scheinen, was ich tue, aber ich bin sehr
dankbar, dass das heiliger Treibstoff ist und es
mich einfach glücklich macht, dazu in der Lage zu sein
auf die Bühne zu gehen und aufzutreten und mein Ding zu machen
und ich bin sehr dankbar dafür  diese
Position, aber ich habe keine großen
Geheimnisse. Ich mache einfach mein Ding und das war's
, aber deine Songs sind sehr, sehr
beliebt, es gibt kein Geheimnis dahinter
, einen populären Song zu schreiben, von dem ich nicht wüsste, dass ich
mich einfach hingesetzt und einen Song geschrieben habe  aber es
gibt überhaupt keine Methode oder kein
Geheimnis, also bist du gesegnet. Ich
würde nicht sagen, dass ich ihn kenne, wie ich
vorher sagte. Ein typischer schottischer Baum ist, dass
wir sehr weit entfernt sind
Ich
würde mich nicht als Musiker bezeichnen, wenn ich das Gefühl
habe, hierher gestolpert zu sein, und ich bin
sehr dankbar dafür, okay, also vielen Dank, danke